the neurological process includes a seer
a series of chemical reaction at the
level of the synapse and and this series
of reaction leads to changes in the
connection the synapses changes that
include both the the SA changes in the
receptors that are located at the
synapses such that this is a receptor
respond in a different way
and change in the release of
neurotransmitter of the synapses and
eventually changes in the the level the
morphology of the synapse such that
their synaptic response becomes much
much stronger and even an addition to
that for this memory to last long there
have to be changes in the at the level
of the genes that
that a part of our DNA and that are long
lasting so there are genetic changes
with the formation of new proteins in
the cells that when live it's you know
like sign it's exchange in the over
there as its plastic changes like as as
more protein and new proteins formed it
does have the sign ups you see memory
passes through several processes to
several point and first you memorize
that I'm saying then you consolidate
this something then you can recall it
when you need to remember then you can
reconsolidated
it's a processor which has several steps
there are phases
I bet that it depends on the particular
moment in which you are trying to recall
that the memory on certain processes
that no longer happen in the brain or
they are blocked some chemical reaction
occur and interfere or do not occur and
interfere with this process of recalling
in a certain moment and then then one
has the chance to dance to remember it
maybe because you make an association or
something in the moment that else to
like you know so if you associate
something with a particular old or I
make sure an example and then that odor
comes then the memory comes up just
those are tricks also to remember
well I mean obviously I bet that smell
is much more important for a dog named
from humans although there are humans
who exercise their sense of smell and a
further probably much better than I am
to remember using smell
I mean there is differences different
between senses a way of learning
according to the people and we're not
the same it's like a door that same
people is more open one door than
another so or so they use in one
particular way more than others so there
are differences but if we accept to the
way in which the memory gets in the
chemical process that once these things
get away they are very very similar
inside the brain they are very very
similar for a different call input of
memory coming from different way through
different mechanism they're very similar
in humans and they are very similar in
between different animals